we're going to Jupiter with the
spacecraft it's going into the worst
radiation field in the solar system and
we think we're ready but no one's ever
done this before well the most important
thing you should know about you know is
we are trying to understand how did you
fit or form in order to understand how
did the solar system form where do we
come from if I want to know how do I get
to making the earth I need to know what
has to fit are made out of Jupiter's
more than twice the mass of all the
other planets combined do you know or a
bit closer to the planet than any other
spacecraft and it will go to higher
latitudes and what we find there will be
a first from an engineer perspective the
thing that's most interesting to me is
how much we can learn about the inside
of the planet when everything we measure
is outside I'm really interested in
understanding what the interior is gonna
tell us what the structure is is there a
core or not all of those questions make
questions about how to plan its form are
the questions that Juno is trying to
answer we are the very first solar power
mission to go this far into the solar
system and one of the reasons why that
works is because we are orbiting Jupiter
in a way that the planet never blocks
the spacecraft's view to the Sun
associated with that our solar arrays
are enormous when you look at our
spacecraft the first thing that jumps
out at you is just the size our solar
arrays are immense our spacecraft is
roughly the size of an NBA basketball
court over the last 20 years or so solar
agency has gotten about 50% better
it really has allowed us to kind of
cross a threshold where it was feasible
to do solar at there's so many different
features in the mission that just tie
together it's like a painting it's like
a work of art it's a beautiful elegant
mission the way it was constructed the
way of us put together it's gonna give
us some beautiful elegant science
literally the planets have to align you
have to launch when Earth and Jupiter
are in the right place because if you
miss that launch date we'd had to wait
well over a year
or we could do the next critical event
we had was opening the solar panels if
you don't get those solar panels open
within the first few hours you don't
have a mission you don't have a
spacecraft you're dead we weren't even
able to test that properly on the ground
we test opening the solar panels but
that's in Earth's gravity jupiter has
the scariest radiation environment of
any planet in the solar system there is
a huge population of energetic electrons
they're moving in almost the speed of
light they basically are like spray of
machine-gun fire hitting a spacecraft
the amount of radiation that would kill
a person is about 1,000 or at a Jupiter
we see approximately 20 million wrath
over the lifetime of our mission it's
kind of like the epic tale man versus
beast David versus Goliath who's gonna
win I don't know